you
hello welcome to Google cloud on-air
it's a live webinar series hosted by
Google cloud we're hosting these
webinars every Tuesday my name is sandy
Jones and today we're gonna talk about
hangouts meet hardware you can ask
questions at any time using the platform
and we have Googlers standing by to
answer those questions as well I'll
handle a few of them at the end of this
session all right let's get started so
like I said today I want to focus in on
Google meeting room solutions I want to
talk about Google's hangout to meet
Hardware originally we're gonna call
this session how G suite customers can
use the new hangouts meet hardware kit
to set up affordable reliable video
conferencing it's scale but apparently
that was a little too wordy so we went
with just hangouts meet hardware but I
thought it was very descriptive so
that's really what we're gonna talk
about today but you know when it comes
to meetings generally people hate them
they typically do most people represent
a proximity loss more than half people
we polled found that meetings were
wasteful use of their time and what that
leads to is most people start
multitasking looking at their phone
maybe checking their email maybe not
paying attention to what's going on at
all and and really most people feel that
that they're having too many meetings
but the reality is meetings are actually
increasing and not decreasing because at
the end of the day they're a fundamental
part of business they're incredibly
important to bringing new ideas to the
table creating solutions to problems and
and most importantly driving consensus
within your organization getting
everybody on the same page so you know
we felt we needed to find a solution to
make these time periods that much more
impactful for the organization now not
only are we getting more meetings that
are getting less productive we're being
asked to attend them from more places
more employees are working remotely but
you still need to be a part of those
meetings no matter whether you're you
know on the other side of the city the
other side of the country around the
world and so you know Google looked into
how we could make meetings more
productive and more impactful and so you
know what we wanted to do was first
increase the presence that you could
achieve in a meeting that would reduce
the multitasking and really want to make
it more of a face-to-face experience I
like to think of there being a social
contract in place when you're face to
face with somebody that kind of demands
your attention and demands that you be
present in the moment as well on top of
all
the body language that you receive while
you're able to see somebody really
increases your ability to evaluate what
they're saying what their mood is and
really what's behind the point they're
trying to get at we also spent a lot of
time analyzing what makes team
successful because typically teams are
an important part of our meetings are
important part of any team engagement
and part of what we found in our rework
with Google you can see there's a URL
there if you want to find more about
these studies what we found was this
concept of psychological safety was the
number one factor in making a team
successful and that meant that they had
to be not afraid to take risks not
afraid to share their ideas and that
came with that face to face interaction
that came with knowing the people you
were working with in a way that was a
lot more intimate than over a phone
telephone conference bridge so Google
kind of took all these insights and we
rolled out our own video conferencing
solution we did this years ago and we
you know in the kind of evolution of
Google as we went from a very small
startup to a multinational organization
we quickly found that video conferencing
was an essential part of our growth
strategy not everybody wanted to move to
Mountain View and pay those real estate
prices and and sit in the traffic so we
found we had to have employees around
the world we also need to be an agile
company that could adapt to market
forces very quickly so we employed video
conferencing solutions to to to do that
and we quickly found there was some
challenges to becoming a video centric
organization first and foremost was
scale we needed a tool that could handle
Google scale Google scale was 100
thousand employees in 50 different
countries we also needed tools that were
easy to use and would drive an
engagement level that we wanted so we
built out our own video conferencing
solution it was made up of twenty
thousand today anyway twenty thousand
video conference enabled meeting rooms
around the world that hosts over 275,000
meetings yeah every day what that adds
up to is ten years of video conferencing
meetings our minutes I should say every
single day think about that for a minute
ten years of video conferencing that
Google produces internally every single
day and like I said through this journey
from you know being a traditional
organization to a video centric
organization we found there's a lot of
challenges and opportunities both in the
video conferencing space and so we need
to build out a toolkit that took
advantage of those things while it
reduced the user friction and so that's
what these four elements you see up on
the screen here really the hardware and
software elements of our meeting room
solution at the core of everything is
Google Hangouts meet it's a software
solution to provide a high quality video
conference meeting from wherever you are
the hardware is for your meeting room so
a hardware kit that creates
enterprise-grade video conferencing from
any meeting space the jam board brings
the whiteboard into the video conference
world and allows you to connect that
whiteboard into the meeting so you can
share your ideas and creations with
anyone that's attached to the meeting
and then the software app allows you to
do that via any mobile device so you can
also participate in that ideation
session so these pieces that really make
up the Google meeting room solution
let's focus in a little bit first on
that Google Hangouts me this is really
where it all began for the Google video
conferencing we created our own tool
deliver that over the web you just went
to a browser type in a URL and you were
part of a meeting and you know of course
we've since made that available on
mobile apps but really the idea is to
make it super easy for anyone to
schedule and join a meeting without even
really happy to think about it because
we don't want to set any barriers to the
adoption of that video first culture now
of course there's not always a time that
you can get on to a video conference
maybe you're driving and you just want
to use the telephone and it's more
traditional manner so that you can still
drive along safely so we added a dial
into every single meeting not only does
this make it possible to kind of choose
how you want to join the meeting and
handle that on-the-go scenario it means
that people may be outside your
organization that are a little bit more
familiar with dial you can easily join
that meeting it also means you can
reduce the cost of a telephone bridge
that you need to support within your
organization now of course there's also
those times when you unexpectedly need
to dial out and that's another piece
that we added so maybe there's a
participant you want to add in
last-minute to your meeting simply dial
their phone number and you can do that
out of any meet to bring them into the
conversation you know one of the things
I notice when I walk around Google is
there isn't a lot of desk phones and
really that's what's allowed us to kind
of get rid of the desk phone
is this like capability for all of our
video conference rooms to allow dialing
and dialogue capabilities now the meet
hardware like I said that's intended to
make the meeting space into an
enterprise-grade meeting room and really
it's you know it's a fairly simple kit
you see there on the left but it
transforms any space into a video
conference room and and again and nuance
that I've noticed that Google is every
single space here is a video conference
room you can go and see a two-person
huddle room that has a screen on the
wall of camera and a little touch pad to
join the meeting you can see large
meeting rooms of 2030 people that are
set up to host large meetings that have
that same kit installed with maybe a
different camera but it allows that
large room to be part of it so really
the goal was to create this hardware kit
that fits any room but creates an
enterprise-grade experience that's easy
to use let's take a look at it in more
detail so at the heart of the hardware
kit is the touch screen that really
allows you to simply tap to go to join
the meeting control the cameras and
every other aspect of the meeting maybe
you want to record the meeting a simple
tap on that same touchpad and now that's
being recorded right into your drive
stream the speaker mic was designed by
Google to be a world-class audio
experience basically to reduce the noise
and the echo that people were getting
over traditional speaker mics so we've
added that into the mix and provided the
latest equipment and software for making
that a crisp echo free experience the
camera options are is actually - and
like I said there's a large and a sort
of smaller regular boardroom flavor for
smaller rooms the huggly camera has
onboard machine learning that will crop
and zoom based on recognizing faces in
the meeting room so this will allow you
to kind of maximize the image and make
for a great user experience without the
users have to do any zoom or pan it also
has a nice wide field of view so it
captures people on the edges if you
think of your traditional kind of four
person or six person room so münster
kind of spread wide instead of long this
wide field of view captures the entire
audience on the larger boardroom size
that's where you have traditionally long
meeting rooms our logic
PTZ - allows you a 10x optical zoom if
you need and the controls built into
that touchpad like I said to control the
camera all from one place the brains of
the meeting room kit is the chrome box
so we keep building these faster and
stronger and more powerful to try and
optimize the quality of the entire
experience but more importantly these
devices all connect into that chrome box
and it handles all the over-the-air
updates so when we come out with a new
echo cancellation algorithm for that
speaker mic its passed down through the
chrome box to the speaker mic connected
to it and you don't have to take care of
manage any of that just happens
automatically over-the-air now when you
think of Google I hope you think of the
world's easiest to use website one text
box and one button and that's a design
philosophy that Google tries to really
bring to anything that we build and I
think we've done an amazing job here by
keeping the idea of Google meeting room
solution simple its first simple on your
budget the goal in making these these
kits was to make a kit that fit every
space and I meant I mean to put in every
space so you don't leave any space
behind right you don't want people
having to make decisions of whether they
have a video conference or not every
room needs to be enabled so when I have
a meeting the video conference is almost
an afterthought because it just happens
but in order to do that we needed a kit
that was affordable on your budget and
would fit into that overall ad spend it
needs to be easy for your end users to a
set up a meeting and then be join that
meeting when they need to and that makes
it in turn easier for you to support
because you don't have users having to
figure things out or trying to trying to
fix equipment in the room that they
should not be fixing so we've made it
very easy further the end users built
right into Google Calendar if you use
Google Calendar you don't have to do
anything other than invite people to
meeting the meeting connection URLs
automatically added to that invite when
you innovate a room that meeting
information is sent right to the room
where it appears on the MIMO touchpad to
use so very easy for your users which
means less support you're gonna have to
do as the the AV team supporting that
and lastly but not least the ease of
install deployment and management
so the actual kind of heavy lifting that
needs to go on behind the scenes to make
this experience we've made that as easy
as possible
fairly plug-and-play on the installation
you connect the pieces together a little
bit of login work just to get the
hardware initialized and away you go
from there it's all managed within the
admin console over-the-air updates make
it easy for me to not have to think
about managing that and like I said you
know the the admin console that you use
to manage G suite is the same place you
go to manage these rooms but not only
that you can manage it scales you can
see all where all your rooms are at what
state they're at we continue adding more
reporting and analytics capabilities as
well as notifications to let you know
proactively
when something's going on with the wrong
with room we're also looking at ways to
help you improve your ROI and there's
sort of a two-fold strategy or one is
that really low price point of these
kits to make sure that you're getting an
ROI on your ad budget when you build out
every single space but also we're
providing metrics on room utilization so
you can take advantage of that real
estate that you've paid for and make
sure it's being used properly and not
being left behind a lot of times when
for example a video conferencing
equipment goes bust that room just
doesn't get used for weeks and weeks but
you're still paying for that in terms of
the real estate costs and the overhead
that ease of use that one-tap I think
that's really one of the the biggest
things I noticed when I came to Google
when I walk into a meeting all I had to
do was to join that meeting was tap on a
touchpad and that's what we've brought
to market with this latest version of
our hangouts meet hardware kit as I said
before when you calendar your event
that's really where the magic starts to
happen Google will help me along the way
to figure out the right room and the
people I need to invite and all that but
it'll also place that meeting URL in the
calendar and send it to the room itself
so I don't do anything I just go into
the room tap and go and my meeting
starts on the screen in front of me I
mentioned the over-the-air updates that
means I don't have to walk around from
room to room to support this Hardware it
simply happens when we pushed out a new
update to any of the attached qualified
peripherals they'll receive that update
and implement that right away they're
self-monitoring itself for remediating
capabilities so the system will try and
correct itself and and mean you don't
have to actually go in and do a restart
er or refresh the system when something
goes wrong it'll try those basic health
fix options before it actually notifies
you and then lastly the automatic
peripheral firmware updates that go
right to that chromebox itself now all
of this is actually also leveraging
something that's Google is very known
for in the YouTube space this global
infrastructure our ability to pass video
around the world and make it available
no matter where you're located we
leverage that same infrastructure of
data centers and networks Google runs
the one of the largest if not the
largest software-defined network in the
world running our own pipes under the
Atlantic and Pacific Ocean my point
being here you're getting the same
ability to move video around the world
that we bring to YouTube now one of the
best aspects of Google Hangouts is the
way it's integrated into G suite that
means a few different things first
there's that easy calendar integration
I've mentioned a few times
once your room is a resource it's gonna
show up in calendar it's gonna
automatically be suggested when it's
near by the user and when it fits the
amount of people that I'm invited the
meeting we're just gonna make that whole
experience of setting up the meeting
very very easy the jam boards also
connected in so maybe I paired my
meeting room hardware with my jam board
it'll ask to join the meeting or I can
just simply type in the code and now my
jam boards are participating in that
meeting Google drive's connected in here
so when I do a recording it's gonna
automatically go into Google Drive I get
the same ease of sharing it with others
that I do with any file type in Google
Drive and really we've made that super
easy from the end-user perspective of
just tapping in and recording on that
touch panel and lastly I've mentioned a
few times the admin console for ease of
manage the other thing about the G suite
integration though is that Google
Hangouts meet is a part of that platform
so right away you're getting a free
video conferencing solution on
everybody's laptop everybody's telephone
that they can begin using right away
okay so that's included in that G suite
bundle that ability to videoconference
to schedule
meetings and really have a
videoconference in my pocket wherever I
go I mentioned a few times this calendar
integration but I do you think that
that's a really key part of the
experience I want to really highlight
that you can see I've got a little sort
of animation here as I'm adding guests
the calendar is gonna suggest guests not
based on alphabetical order but based on
a machine learning algorithm that knows
I work with Katie a lot so I'll put her
at the top because that's who I'm
typically meeting with or you know these
are some people I've had some recent
interactions with so let's pop them into
the list as well because there's
obviously a lot going on with them right
now and as I type it's gonna get even
smarter so you know after I put in an S
we'll just have Scott and Rivest and on
that list there as well and then of
course when it gets to finding a time
once I've got my guests maybe they're
not all available at that time I can
look for times but the system also
suggests times for me and make it easy
for me to to find a time where we can
all meet adding rooms it will suggest
rooms based on the locations of the
participants so when I'm scheduling
meeting for people in New York it's a
guess just New York rooms but if I have
a few people on the west coast it'll
give me two sets of suggestions one for
New York and maybe one for Mountain View
in the room that calendar invite just
gets passed right to the touchpad and so
I'll see all the events that are
scheduled for that day and I can simply
tap on my meeting to join that whenever
that comes up and that touchpad has full
control capabilities of both the camera
my ability to record the meeting it'll
also show me the in calendar context of
the meeting so a lot of times you know
you get going back to back from meeting
a meeting you're not even sure what
you're walking into you don't have time
to pull it up on your phone or your your
laptop maybe but you can just tap a
button on the the touchpad
and see the details of the meeting and
just get yourself a few more seconds of
being caught up before you jump in I
mentioned the jam board a few times and
and there's probably a whole hour we
could put on the jam board conversation
but the idea here was to bring the
whiteboard into the video conference
world probably a lot of you have been on
video conferences where somebody at the
other end of the video conference has
had a whiteboard
you get kind of this poor experience and
don't get to actually share in the
ability to create ideas or correct
problems that are on that whiteboard
maybe you don't even get to see the
whiteboard very well because it's off to
an angle or or not that easy to see
through the camera and you think about
the whiteboard it's it's been around
since people were drawing in the sand
it's that open space that you create
ideas and solve problems or huddle
around a last minute problem that needs
to be handled in a new and unexpected
way and so losing that tool in a video
conference world we found that that
create a lot of friction for Google we
invented the jam board to kind of solve
for that it allows you to connect the
boards to each other individually or
connect into the meeting and share that
white sports board space with any
participant that's on there and as I
mentioned all this is seamlessly
integrated in G suite when you deploy G
suite you get the all the benefits of
Google hangout meet and when you add in
the meeting rooms they just become a
part of the calendar and a part of the
user experience now more recently we've
added even more power to the Google
Hangouts meet capabilities and that's
through a partnership with our friends
over at peck's it so we've created a
native Interop solution that allows
anyone to join a Google hangout meat
from a sip h.323 endpoint such as Cisco
Polycom life-size or from Skype for
business so really what this means is
when you schedule an event the same way
it easily creates a link for you to join
a hangout you now gain a link to join
from those other endpoints so I have the
ability to go onto a Cisco endpoint
punch in my code and joining that
hangout meet that's bringing that legacy
investment that you maybe have in some
of your meeting rooms and bringing that
into the Google hangout meet world as
well so if I have some spaces that I've
already heavily invested in I can now
take advantage of that investment while
still rolling out Google Hangouts meet
Hardware in some of my smaller less to
use rooms it also means that if I'm
working with people that maybe aren't on
Google Hangouts meet maybe they're on
one of these other systems I'm able to
send them an invite and we're able to
collaborate together
online as well you can see here just a
kind of a glamour shot of all the
companies we work with on the Google
Hangouts meat side I think the real
thick takeaway here is that this is a
solution that fits customers of all
sizes so whether it's a small company
that traditionally wouldn't be able to
afford video conferencing or large
organizations that are really looking to
increase their collaboration and
transform their culture every
organization can take advantage of the
Google Hangouts meet solution if you
have any questions on Google Hangouts
meat we've created this alias here
meeting - room - pod at google.com so
that's myself and my team we're standing
by to answer follow-up questions or
things that maybe just go beyond this
session today but definitely if you'd
like to set up a follow-up conversation
feel free to reach out of this email and
get a hold of us so that's it for the
kind of lecture portion of this stay
tuned for life
you
alright welcome back and now I'd like to
take a few questions from the audience
so we've put a few up here by all means
feel free to keep asking questions we
have people online wait and help you
with those but let's start off with the
first one what is the cost for the
meeting hardware kit okay so we have two
flavors of a meeting hardware kit
there's the kind of regular size room
and I think this is anything 10 people
or less as well as our large room kit as
well it's approximately $2,000 for the
regular size kit and that comes with a
camera a speaker mic the chrome box and
the touchpad
you bring your own monitor we didn't
want to sort of force people into a
particular monitor since different rooms
require different sizes and you may
already have an existing monitor
investment or screen investment that
you're able to take advantage of the
larger kit which comes with the touchpad
chrome box speaker mic and a Logitech
PTZ 2 camera is approximately $2,500 and
you can find more about that online as
well why is the new hangouts meat
Hardware better or different than old
chromebox for meetings so there's
there's a bit to this there's sort of
the software side and the hardware side
so let's talk just the hardware side for
now when we first came out with the
chromebox for meetings the idea was to
create a disruptive video conferencing
kit right we wanted to find a price
point that meant every meeting space
could have video conference inside of it
and our first foray was to for all
intents and purposes really build a kit
from consumer available peripherals so
the camera that came with it you could
probably buy it best by the speaker Mike
was a fairly basic puck configuration
and now of course at the chrome box but
it leveraged a remote control instead of
the touchscreen and that provided the
the disruption that we were looking for
it definitely allowed companies to place
these kits in more spaces it was almost
half the cost of our existing hardware
kit today but what we also found was it
wasn't the enterprise-grade that our
customers were
expecting from the the G suite and
Google products so we went back to the
drawing board we did do a lot on the
software side I'll talk about that a
little bit later but but on the hardware
side we re-engineered every aspect of it
so we introduced the MIMO touchpad
instead of using the controller that
created a much better user experience so
instead of navigating up and down and
have to use a small controller if you're
like me and sometimes forget your
glasses that can be almost an impossible
task but it was replaced by the simple
touch tap and go functionality of the
touchscreen
we took the speaker mic and
re-engineered that from the ground up
really focusing in on noise and echo
cancellation so you get a higher quality
audio but you also get less interference
and less distraction we also
reengineered the chromebox we
continually improve that and provide
better specs and hardware pieces and
then lastly we introduced two new camera
options one was the Logitech PT Zhu PTZ
- sorry as well as the hudley camera
which has onboard machine learning that
supports the auto crop and zoom that I
mentioned earlier to just make the
maximum sort of impact for four
different users see here what's better
about meet Hardware ever it's just
joining calls from my laptop I think
really it's about what your use case is
so the meet hardware was intended to go
in the meeting room space there's a lot
of times where you just need to meet as
a group and by no means do I think video
conference has gotten the point where it
out does the in-person meeting so you're
still gonna have people meeting in
person but a lot of times you're gonna
have a mixed group where maybe five oh
you're in the same location but another
five or even one person is remote that
remote person can join from their laptop
whereas the five you can be in the room
if you've ever been in one meeting room
where five people have tried to join
from the same laptop you notice it's
fraught with problems first of all
there's the inevitable noise that's
created by the the feedback loop as
everybody's joining and their audio goes
into the speaker mic you can reduce that
by just using one person lap one
person's laptop but now everybody's
huddling around and really you're only
seeing one person on that so the goal
behind the meet Hardware kit
was the videoconference enable your room
and really make it so that I'm meeting
as if I'm face-to-face but I'm using the
video conferencing solution to do that
the laptop is more for that one person
that's remote or where I have to join
where I don't have a meeting room
available so really I guess to answer
that question it's really about the
space you're using and we would still
highly recommend outfitting your meeting
rooms with the hardware kit we have a
lot of investment in our existing
meeting rooms with Cisco Polygram and
etc is hangouts meat compatible and and
there's more say yes it is I would just
talk about that Peck sip partnership you
can definitely find out more by reaching
out to us or our friends at Peck sip
they're very excited about this
partnership as well what it really boils
down to is when you create that calendar
invite in addition to scheduling the
hangouts meet it will also provide
options for how to join via the Cisco
and Polycom and and other SIP h.323
endpoints as well as Skype for business
as I mentioned this is a partnership
with Peck sip so I would definitely want
to talk to you about how you make that
available for your company and what's
involved in setting up this integration
Hangouts meet vs. hangouts classic so
this is really that software question
before I talk about the hardware side of
the differences between the new hangouts
meet hardware versus old chromebox for
meetings now let's talk about the
software side so the origin of Google
Hangouts was actually Google+ so you
know we built that as kind of a social
media solution it was intended that
families could meet using Google Google
Hangouts or friends could catch up even
though they were separated by a lot of
distance and while that was successful
what was even more successful was
businesses using that to conduct their
business so that's what kind of led us
to bring that into the G suite family
and like I said that was again sort of
this intention of taking a consumer tool
and disrupting the enterprise space
something that's very popular with
technology companies these days and what
we found was although we had a really
good experience with hangouts meet there
was enterprise features that we didn't
think about in that Google Plus use case
recording is a great example of that
right
having that high quality experience it's
great example that phone dial in and
dial out are examples of those
enterprise-grade features that really
didn't come up when you thought about
building a consumer tool but had to be a
part of the solution so hangouts meat
really represents an entire rebuild of
the architecture of Google Hangouts and
the focus this time is on building a
tool that's ready for the enterprise and
provides that enterprise grade
experience where can i buy hangouts meat
hardware so this is sort of a geography
question as well as a I guess a tactical
question so Google Hangouts meat
hardware is available in North America
the EU as well as the new kit as well as
Japan and Australia that we do have ways
of importing into other countries as
well and it's really through our partner
network that we do that so we actually
sell the hardware through our partner
network you can go online at on
google.com just search for Google
Hangouts meat you'll find some places
you can buy online as well through the
Google store but at the end of day we
would recommend reaching out to your G
sweet partner and typically they're
gonna also sell this hardware as well if
I have deployment questions or need tips
are there helpful resources for me
absolutely there is one thing that we've
just caught a sort of soft launch is a
room design guide you know we are
probably the largest users of this
Google Hangouts meat technology and
we've used that experience and put that
into a guide our own a/b team is
actually taking their time to build out
a guide that that outlines the best
practices in terms of you know designing
the room from how you set up the chairs
and how you set up your monitors to the
hardware you need in there and how you
connect it all together so you know the
URL that is rating that URL the email
address meeting - room - pod at
google.com I'll repeat that again
meeting - room - pod is a great way to
reach out to us and get more information
on that as well as there's a whole host
of materials online a best practices
guide for setting up your network that's
something to consider as
you decide you need to become a video
conference enabled company is how do you
make sure your network can handle that
extra load we've got a lot of best
practices on on optimizing that network
setting it up and how to have a great
experience with that so with that that's
the the end of the questions I want to
thank everyone for watching and please
tune in next Tuesday for the next
session of Google cloud on air thank you
very much have a great day everybody